So
the state of Nevada did something very important
yesterday, and after they did it, Donald Trump
absolutely exploded it and another one of
these fits of rage.
What Nevada did is they approved sending every
registered voter and absentee ballot rather
than sending out applications which have to
be returned in order to get an absentee ballot.
Instead of saying simply if you want an absentee
ballot, you have to print and send us the
absentee ballot application.
They had approved by the state legislature
and expected to be signed into law by the
Democratic governor, a bill which will say,
if you're a registered voter, we will send
you a ballot.
Donald Trump immediately took to Twitter to
furiously say, quote, In any legal late night
coup, Nevada's clubhouse governor made it
impossible for Republicans to win.
The state post office could never handle the
traffic of mail in votes without preparation
using coded to steal the state.
See you in capital C..
Caught.
Now, it's actually a linguistic feat that
Donald Trump has accomplished, squeezing so
many lies and distortions into such a small
number of characters.
It's interesting that this is now sort of
the battle line when it comes to the election
and how and when the November election will
take place has become one of the biggest stories
among many big stories right now.
Donald Trump, first of all, claiming that
it is illegal for Nevada to do this.
It's not.
States run their own elections.
They can do this if they want.
They are not sending absentee ballots.
Trump says multiple ballots to the same people
or ballots to kids or undocumented immigrants
or whatever the case may be.
Ballots are going to registered voters and
states have a right to do that.
Secondly, it is not impossible for Republicans
to win with mail in voting in a literal sense.
But Donald Trump seems to recognize that in
order to win, he needs to suppress the vote
and he disproportionately needs to suppress
the Democratic vote.
Since Democrats take the virus more seriously
than Republicans, if you make it more difficult
to voter at least more risky in terms of catching
the virus to vote, you will probably dissuade
more Democrats than Republicans from voting.
It's a simple numbers game, and the polling
I showed you yesterday bears that out.
Democrats, by taking Corona virus more seriously,
might be more likely to say, if I have to
go in person, I'll I'm going to stay home.
Whereas Republicans, because they are not
taking the virus seriously, are more likely
to say, if I can't vote by mail, I will go
in and vote.
So it's a strategy and it's a very clear strategy.
Notice also that Donald Trump mentions the
post office can't handle the traffic of mail
in ballots.
He himself is trying to kneecap the post office
he appointed as postmaster general.
A big donor to his campaign.
Lewis Dejoy Lewis Dejoy immediately decided
to restrict overtime for postal workers.
We talked about it in detail earlier, and
it looks as though Lewis Dejoy is also starting
to explore the possibility of closing some
post office branches.
So again, Trump citing problems that he is
causing as the reason why we shouldn't do
something.
And then lastly, you know, see you in court
is accurate in a sense.
And Trump is filing lawsuits.
That might be a preview of what we can expect
in November, depending on what the results
of the election are.
We may see many elements of this tied up in
court.
And what Trump is essentially saying is, how
can I possibly win if every American is easily
allowed to vote without fear of catching the
virus?
That's fundamentally what this is about.
It is completely authoritarian.
It is completely anti-democratic.
And the answer is, if everybody really is
able to vote safely, Trump may not be able
to win.
If you look at the polling and you look at
the partizan split on vote by mail versus
vote in person, it is not a crazy suggestion
to make that if the will of the people is
accurately represented and not hampered by
kneecapping the post office or preventing
vote by mail.
Trump may not be able to win because people
want to vote him out.
Now the polling may change and of course,
Trump may suppress enough of the Democratic
vote that he does get reelected, but he may
accurately be perceiving that, although he
wouldn't say it in those words.
Now, lastly, this idea of the post office
being unable to handle mail in ballots, certainly
Trump is trying to make it so that they wouldn't
be able to handle it.
But as it stands today, the post office would
be very well equipped to handle mail in ballots.
The post office handles unconscionable numbers
of pieces of mail.
And as long as we don't deliberately destroy
the post office, which is what Trump is trying
to do, the post office will have no problem
handling mail.
So fundamentally, this comes down to what
is one of the few, Stratis? Trump now has
to take control of the election.
I told you about that poll yesterday, which
showed two thirds of those planning to vote
in person are Trump supporters, whereas 75
percent of those planning to vote by mail
are Biden supporters.
That is the data which explains why Trump
is so furiously against vote by mail.
Trump's strategy is not to be a good president,
so people want to vote for him.
That opportunity has sadly come and gone.
The strategy is suppress the vote, suppress
the vote while kneecapping the post office.
Try to prevent vote by mail in order to try
to sneak into another four years in office.
We can't allow it to happen, but we need to
vote in order to prevent it